do you know what bugs the out of me
this is the killer reach and not
defining it as potential reach and
assuming it's actualized reach it
destroys me it's garbage data it
completely takes common sense and a
pulse of culture off the table it kills
me and we talk about it as if it's true
one question an amazing lineup of CEOs
Founders and experts this is marketing
for the now attention is the number one
asset hey Gary I thought I saw you walk
by
I am here I late everybody let me
apologize
for you don't need to apologize because
you know what I was giving not not to
you because I know we're family and I
feel comfortable I'm talking about Chris
S on LinkedIn and Jessica Knight on
LinkedIn and danne weathers on LinkedIn
and Cody Weaver on LinkedIn so um I just
needed to apologize to them excellent
well I'm GNA just let you guys riff
because Diana has a lot to share and uh
we can't wait to hear
it no pleasure Diana how are you I'm
good how
are I am I am well it's nice I've seen
you three times now in the last like six
weeks this is exciting I know I know and
you know we have a call
later so so let's go right into it like
knowing your background um being fond of
your work feel that you actually have
you know for everybody's watching I do
feel like the more senior you get in
these big corporations
it becomes more challenging I don't R
I'm empathetic it gets harder to be
closer to the pulse to the street um but
I think you've done a really nice job
watching you from afar and so answer
this question directly like what do you
on this brand forance like how do people
balance brand building and performance
from your
perspective yeah I think you know not to
be contrarian I just have a different
viewpoint on of it and I actually don't
think these things are two separate
things I don't
either I approach as when I heard you at
the CMO Summit and like no notice
balancing like I believe balancing is
could be looked at two different ways to
your point opposites or actually the
purple yeah so they complement each
other and if you really think about it
and what we try to do with the brands
that I work on the team that I have at
Colgate P model like I have the
privilege of leading what we call the
consumer experience and growth team
which means nothing to anyone but really
what we've done is rethought about what
marketing for the future for now in this
complex consumer driven environment
really means and so we put the consumer
at the center of everything so what does
that mean so my team has Revenue growth
management insights data and Advance
analytics but also some of those
traditional um CMO elements that you
would think of when it comes to digital
Commerce or brand building or creative
or social or um just traditional media
and the reason why we did that is is a
consumer experience is just not about
brand love it's not about you know
actually experiencing the product uh
it's not just about seeing an ad that
you fall in love with it really is the
entire touch point so from when I get
the product at the zero Moment of Truth
and I'm in consideration all the way to
the second Moment of Truth where I
actually experience the product which is
really where you drive and build Brands
um all of those touch points matter and
how we make that experience more
exceptional and what are the jobs to be
done so that we really build the brand
you know at Colgate we have brands that
are 27 year old like Colgate toothbrush
which you all know and love and are have
in your shelves but we also have newer
Brands like hello which is a very
designed forward brand countertop
friendly but really thinks about the
consumer experience at every single
touch point so a long way of say saying
every every touch point in marketing is
performance driving every touch point in
marketing should be brand building and
if you don't think about it that way
then you're not thinking from a human or
a consumer lens
why explain to all the people that are
watching because what normally happens
is like I'm looking at the chat right
now we're doing this on LinkedIn
exclusively today this is obviously
gonna be on my podcast we're gonna cut
this up and chop this up and put it
everywhere explain you know obviously
the corporate people are going to
understand this but go down into the
trenches of the audience I'm seeing here
explain to people why corporations
because your statement makes so much
sense I came from small business and
startup land why have big Market
organizations the fortune 00s why why
are they not consumer Centric why are
they Academia Centric or corporate
Centric I I I don't think the large so
my sweet spot is a 1002 200 year old
company that's my that's where I come
into play and I don't think that they're
not consumer Centric I think it's an end
they're consumer Centric but when you're
a big ship and you've been around that
long to be able to be around for another
200 years you have to make sure that
you're you know from a finance
standpoint that you have smart
accounting principles that legal is your
best friend when you're a larger brand
you become a legal Target so all of
those things create another lever I
think it's how you think and approach
them so my best friends at work my head
of legal my CFO HR as well too because
you can't get the right talent for your
roles without that and I think right now
a lot of folks approach them especially
in marketing teams as oh we got to get
around legal or oh you know we got to
try to convince the CFO that this is a
good idea rather than bringing them
along for the journey so at the end of
the day what does the CFO want what do
even I want I want to get my bonus we
want to deliver um a profit back to um
you know our investor community so how
do we do that well we create these brand
experiences so really being able to link
and connect the two uh is important and
understanding the flexibility that we
need in a p&l to to be able to move at
the speed of culture you just have to
bring your CFO folks along and then
legal plays such a critical role
especially in a social environment
wanting to be in the moment of culture
uh working with your legal partner so
you can do it in a in a way that
actually protects your Brands and allows
you to do things that are appropriate
and don't open you up uh for litigation
so it's not that they're not brand
obsessed it's that the bigger you get
you know they say More Money More
Problems the bigger you get the more
that you have to be thoughtful about
maintaining a position and I would say
the last thing that is really critical
for larger companies that they have to
work on when you have a large company
it's just like being in a big family you
have workers in the factory you have
workers across multiple markets and you
want to make sure that you don't make
decisions that risk their livelihood as
well too the stakes are higher so that's
really what's driving some of the extra
layers that you have to maneuver through
when you're in a bigger Corporation the
thing that I'm curious about from your
perspective is the extra layers lead to
less speed right water down those those
were not as big of an issue in a small
in a slower world yes when your
competitors were also spending six
months to put out a commercial you know
that's one thing but obviously for
example Colgate we all know it we all
love it like in there's been a lot of
innovation yeah in your space and those
smaller
entrepreneurs with the you know the
advantages of being able to be in retail
or have the money to do media have
changed a lot in a world where Shopify
can represent a Shopify store can
represent the ability to reach consumers
the way being in all the Walmarts used
to or that social can now represent what
commercials did what what are you know
knowing that you in that sweet spot have
been around 200 year old companies what
do you think the best big companies
what's the best behaviors that you've
seen from big companies to actually get
good at um the nimbleness needed to be
great at building brand and getting
performance I I tell this to son and
it's the same thing I approach business
with you can't be a me too you can't go
after hey the small guys do it this way
no you've got to own your own space so
we are typically in most categories we
in there incumbent we do have smaller um
know you know disruptor brands that
we're also building but if you but
specifically focus on those incumbent
Brands leverage the scale those smaller
Brands they would love the brand loyalty
the scale the fact that you know Colgate
itself is the number one household pen
rent in the planet like that's not a
low-key brag that those are just facts
and so to have that brand love to play
with so yes can they move with speed in
certain areas that I cannot that is true
but what I have to work with from an
already emotional connection with my
consumer um advocacy and um consumer
love that you know when I have a brand
like fabuloso before I can even put
something on social we had people dress
up like fabuloso for Halloween this year
and send that to us so there are
intangible things that we have that are
different and you got to play to your
strengths and your skill set and if you
try to focus on hey I need to operate
like you know the startup Brands then
you just look like the old dude in the
club like you really have to think about
okay what is ownable for my brand where
should I play and then how as the bigger
brand do I help grow the category itself
and I think if you understand your
responsibilities as the larger incumbent
brand and you play them well I I will
tell you there's a lot of space in these
categories consumers love choice and
you'll enable them to make the choice
that is right for them I think the other
thing that large brands have and
especially that we have at Colgate is
the efficacy of our product delivering
at the end of the game the end of course
and knowing that the biggest way to
build Brands is to have an incredible
brand experience and to have that be
scienced back the way it is by us
knowing that every time the consumer is
going to get that experience that
they're looking for that's that's when
you really win or lose so it's how you
place those bets and Investments but no
I'm not going to be able to see
something relevant in the C culture and
then post something five minutes later
but what we were able to do with the Met
Gala when we saw that the carpet looked
like you know Colgate toothpaste we were
able to get something up and out the
door in an hour which is of SP more than
fast enough a company that you know we
play with I love you I hope you have a
great day great end of the year have a
good Thanksgiving thanks for coming on
fantastic we've got a new friend up next
G you've got Janelle Tavis who runs
Bugaboo which is one of my favorite
Brands uh in North America and I didn't
realize it's a Dutch
based she gonna yeah she's gonna lay it
down for us give us a little some Global
insights as well welcome Janelle amazing
thank you for having me this is actually
our first time meeting Gary so it's such
a treat to be here thank you I uh thank
you I uh I uh know the brand very well
so I'm pretty pumped you're here why
don't you tell the people that might not
be in that life cycle about the brand
for a minute or two and then we'll get
the JY but thank you for being here yeah
amazing so I'll set the stage a little
bit for sure before I came to Bugaboo I
actually spent nearly a decade at Nike
and I think whether you sell strollers
or you sell sneakers it was really
interesting to hear you and Diana but I
think what the great Brands actually
really do is put the consumer at the
center and what we do at Bugaboo that
consumer is the new parent so Bugaboo is
a parenting Solutions brand and as you
said we're best known for for our high
performance and Innovation strollers and
uh European founded so our our design
team and our Innovation team actually
sit out of the Netherlands and I look
after the the US and Canadian business
so it's a real honor to be here thank
you for the people that like Drive
luxury cars or you know like it is it is
the Rolls-Royce of of strollers um and
being a New York City parent you need a
really strong machine and so I'm um talk
to me about this I'm actually genuinely
curious um about because I think Dan is
right about like performance and brand
shouldn't be separate it's more of the
gray of the black and white but most
marketing organizations are structured
with it being like brand over here
performance over here how do y all think
about it and what's your current state
of the union on what you feel inside
about the challenges or the
opportunities in performance the
challenges and the opportunities in
doing bigger brand work that creates
affinity and how do you think about this
ju's position yeah such a good question
so again I want to I want to pull us
back um because I think the first thing
that any any great brand should do and
what I would offer to the room of CEOs
and Founders and Executives watching
this today is really just to first start
off with putting your consumer in the
center and understanding where is your
consumer coming from how are they
finding you and then also most
importantly where are the gaps and then
you can decide then whether or not you
want to spend that Dollar on a brand
awareness building campaign or a
performance campaign so again just to to
give you an actual example of how we see
it at Bugaboo as as I mentioned before
in the setup Bugaboo is a a Dutch design
company on the other side of the pond in
Europe really strong brand awareness
Deep Roots but then when you come over
here to the US right we're we're
actually seeing really incredible growth
the last three years but when we pulled
a room of 100 expecting parents I mean
I'm so happy that you're familiar with
the brand because it was actually
singled digit awareness you think I'm
sorry to interrupt yeah you know on the
awareness front cor correct me if I'm
wrong it is a premium product yes 100%
yes it's a premium product that any
parent can tell you I mean I'm also a
New York a New York mom that you can
really tell the difference in when
you're pushing down you know the streets
of the Upper West Side and it's pouring
rain and you got to get to Z Bars and
fill the the under seat basket with
groceries I mean you need a performance
ride and even if you're not a New York
parent if you are you live in Suburbia
you're going to want a stroller that
folds really easy and you can throw in
the back of by the way by the way that
that little rant you had about Upper
East Side Zabar's rain you need to clip
that and you need to run that on
Instagram Tik Tok and Facebook against
New York City mom demo like that little
clip right there I think would be one of
your top Performance Brand performance
taking taking notes and all they need to
do is just follow me in the day in the
life of like trying to get my
three-year-old and and and and
ingredients and dinner on the table so
but that's that's exactly it so to go
back to your question what is what is
that tension I think it just f it it
comes down to what is your consumer
experiencing how do you create emotional
storytelling and high quality content
that resonates with the the problem that
your consumer is wrestling with and
therefore as a brand this solution that
you're offering and then you put dollars
behind it in the spaces that you know
that your consumer is the most so for
example at Bugaboo we know that late 20s
something year old early 30s all the way
up until now mid 40s starting to become
first-time parents they're spending a
lot of time on social media I know I
don't need to tell you this so that is
really where we want to show up in that
part of the consumer Journey where
they're researching or they're wondering
hey what is everyone talking about what
is everyone wearing the Facebook groups
are just like such a a wealth of
information for that expectant parent
that really doesn't know what to do in
this new chapter of their life so I
think you know just to kind of summarize
it it's one it's putting the consumer at
the center can can I jump in there yeah
one thing we're obsessed at at bner
xland that we don't see people doing in
the broader marketing world is consumer
at the center to your point 27y old
Upper West Side firsttime mom Young by
New York standards coming from a third
generation wealthy
family versus 41-year-old firsttime Mom
Upper East Side coming from the streets
and her husband her wife have made
it already immediately have a very
different
psychographic reality yeah how you know
do you find it challenging like every
other brand I speak to every day for the
last decade and especially last three
years of not being able to make enough
creative at a good enough cost to be
able to be relevant to as many different
consumer at the center in my mind for a
brand even at the size of Bugaboo which
is not Nike or Colgate but still a big
brand yeah 30 40 50 60 different
specific consumer segmentations to make
up the customer but creative is so
expensive when you work with agencies or
even internally is when you think about
Compu at the center do you try to
generalize it in one lump or you think
thinking in this cohort consumer
segmentation model yeah it's such a good
question and I think the short answer is
is that as a brand if you talk to
everybody you're you're actually talking
to nobody so you really have to be
specific about who is our consumer Muse
everything from their age demographic to
the to the other brands that they like
where do they live where do they shop
what are they looking for so when we are
creating content yes you create a
profile of of the consumer that you're
speaking to and that resonate outside of
that but then you're making sure that
you're being really focused so at again
at Bugaboo this is the new parent at
Nike it's the athlete it's it's the it's
the kid who's who's trying to start
their first run or starting their first
basketball game the new the new the
thing I'm fascinated by the challenge
that I perceive you may have and others
that are similar the new pairing comes
in so many shapes and sizes yeah but
what we're actually finding is that
whether to to paint that picture if
they're the 2 seven-year old upper wests
side parent or they are 40 something and
they and they live in Oklahoma actually
their drivers are the same yeah but to
stop them yeah to stop them scrolling to
stop them on
relevance to create the consumption of
those tried and true is the thing I'm
fascinated by I couldn't agree with you
more most humans when you bleed them
down have the similar 10 things my
concern and obsession is getting
permission for them to listen requires
relevance and that's where it gets real
different of what they need to see and
hear yeah and we we struggle with the
same thing how do you stop the scroll
yeah and and stopping the scroll as you
as you probably agree is not just even
though we know it's the dominant Force
now that still is TV that still is a
billboard that still is like it's still
all of it stop the scroll is like a Omni
battle right yeah I gotta say though
whatever your content is I'm always
stopping my scroll because I think
amazing let's let's definitely collect
now that I know you're in New York I'll
ask and Andrea to set us up 100% would
love that thank you for having me Gary I
want give you one more second because I
jumped in there a lot because I was F
that what did we not touch on that you
might have wanted to touch on or let
people
know uh let's see if I think I would
like to just I mean let's just summarize
all the great points that we talked
about and leave your listeners with some
takeaways so um I think all great Brands
they they actually do understand their
consumer really well start with the
insights start start with a deep
understanding of your consumer mindset
focus on emotional storytelling connect
your products into your consumer and the
last thing that I'll say um is make sure
that you're all scoring off the same
scorecard because make sure that you
have the same version of success on what
you're trying to do because as a
marketer you want to make sure that you
align with Finance with sales on what
that campaign Target is and just make
sure that you have a singular metric of
success in order to be successful love
it thank you Joe thank you Gary thanks
Janelle all right Gary we have another
new friend coming up Kate Lamberton you
might remember that Jim stangle and Kate
did they authored this incredible
article in Harvard Business Review that
was all about brand format so we've got
her here today to lay down all the
insights and findings welcome Kate thank
you so much so happy to be here hi Kate
how are you I'm great how are you I'm
well I'm super aware and so I'm gonna
let you take the floor you wrote the
manifesto while don't you why don't you
give everybody a little bit of your
thesis observations the things you're
saying yeah it's been really interesting
to listen to your prior guests because I
think we're all on the same page uh from
from the very opening where there is no
division here to we need a metric that
puts us on the same scorecard exactly
amazing these people are brilliant and
they're doing it in the real world um it
was really interesting because I was
working a few years ago I teach among
other things I teach in marketing to
Wharton you know a thousand Wharton
undergrads a year and I have this class
on brand measurement how are the kids
today in marketing like like just for
two seconds because this is fascinating
to me are they overly pot committed to
Social and not thinking 360 do they go
into the academic environment maybe over
indexing on over respecting some of
yesterday even though they're living
differently as consumers something in
between everyone's different what's the
vibe you know I think what's great about
them is that they will ask questions
about all of it I mean they're going to
interrogate any claim you put in front
of them and thank God right because
we've had a couple years of just
honestly investment in Vapor right oh
this is the hot thing that's the hot
thing and so what they actually want are
Frameworks to Think Through the things
because the things are going to change
they're gonna keep changing and so it's
not helpful to have a class on Tik Tok
what's helpful is to have a class on how
media works and how exposure and reach
affect Behavior then whatever the new
thing is they can analyze it is there
gonna one more thing before I let you go
of course I completely went against what
I said but I've got you here and I gotta
ask reach do you know what bugs the
out of me tell me something I'm sure
there are a couple things there are a
couple things but this is the killer
reach and not defining it as potential
reach and assuming it's actualized reach
destroys me okay it destroys me it's
garbage data in a lot of it's It's
devastating it completely takes common
sense and a pulse of culture off the
goddamn table it kills me and we talk
about it as if it's true and and this is
the kind of thing that I think
performance marketers get focused on
because they're given a dashboard and
they're supposed to hit these numbers
and it's not a meaningful number it's
just a number and once you have a number
then you chase it um and I think this
actually takes us back to this question
of brand right because what that reach
means in the context of a strong or
ascending brand is completely different
than what it means when your brand is is
in is in garbage world right and so you
know when we when we talk about this
stuff in research it's an interaction
the effect of X on y depends on Z right
so the effect of reach on any out any
given outcome is going to depend on
about five different things maybe 50
different things in fact so on its own
it's it's not a meaningful metric um but
it's it's what gets used to sell a lot
um and but again that's what I love
these students they will interrogate
they will push they will chase and I
think that's a hopeful sign great all
right go back to the manifesto what okay
okay so Manifesto so so uh I'm looking
for brand measurements and most of the
brand measurements I'm finding I'm
like how is that manager really useful
like that's fine you can give me a brand
ranking I don't know what to do with it
right and again these students are gonna
push me if if I give them something like
that so you know 60% of my class is
finance majors and they're like what is
how do how I put that on back I'm glad
that interbrand can tell me a value and
put it on an asset sheet but how do I
then talk to anybody about it and so I
ran across this company um that does
what I think is actually I don't want to
plug but they I thought they were doing
smarter
things yeah they do smarter things I'm
sorry I didn't catch it called Bara
B um with brand measurement and tracking
and connecting brand measurement to the
equ the measurement of brand Equity to
both Upstream like upstairs consequences
like things the CFO cares about
um and what's happening on the
performance side and what's happening on
the brand side and in talking to them
what became apparent was that if you
don't have this bridging metric that
connects performance to Brand you
actually everybody loses um because
brand has an effect on the finance
relevant kpis through its enhancement of
best case what's happening in
performance performance if it's being
done well will directly amplify the
effect that brand has the two of them
then go into this metric and actually
both of them can be accountable and both
of them can have short and long-term
effects that can be captured over time
right now what happens is people say
performance is shortterm and it can be
held accountable brand is longterm and
we just have to wait actually not
actually both can be accountable and
that's good news because both keep their
piece of budget but you need this
bridging brand this brand Equity metric
or it's not really possible I totally I
to couldn't I talk about it as purple
right I'm writing uh a new book and the
cover is purple because the thesis is if
using the political structure in the US
which is very contentious if the the
world of marketing is red or blue the
Magic's in the purple yeah I mean and
it's also it's also though I think still
understanding the distinctions right I
wouldn't want to lose the red and the
blue because they do different things
right and so so you have this this
metric and so theirs they break it into
familiarity regard meaning and
uniqueness and what's nice there is if
you capture this and you see for example
in an older brand say you're talking
about one of these brilliant 200 year
old Brands familiarity is easy regard
plenty as it ages you got to build
uniqueness right so then what you can
say is here's what performance when we
do this performance action here's how
uniqueness is
changing and this is the part of the
brand we need to work on so we need to
select the performance that we can show
a relationship to uniqueness that's
where our brand is right now before I
lose you why do you think so many people
in in modern agencies and Brands
struggle with relevance at scale oh
because it's it's almost it's very very
hard I mean it's incredibly hard but I
think it what the the the the trick and
I'm not going to say there's an easy
answer because there's not for any of
this stuff or we don't have a job but
it's picking the the level at which the
segmentation operates um for me what is
often underappreciated is that the
segmentation criteria that matters the
most is the information processing style
that's in play at any moment so when you
guys were talking about the Upper East
Side Upper West Side mom yes of course
if you're trying to go to I want to give
you an image that specifically resonates
with you yeah that's that's tricky you
got to use some behavioral day to match
that up but if what you can say is both
of these moms are when they're wrestling
with their Bugaboo um emotionally
stressed under time pressure etc etc you
know a general class of of creative
that's going to work for them it's going
to be quick hit simple message you know
what I you know what I love yep you know
what I love about what you said I think
one of the reasons we were able to excel
past the market in Social is that is the
same philosophy we deploy against the
different social networks because we
know the people right now that are
consuming something on
LinkedIn versus if they were on lunch in
their office LinkedIn versus on lunch
Tik Tok is a different version of thems
yes exactly and that's actually what
matters I mean I can tell you and I say
this all the time Amazon has no idea who
I am because although I have no children
I've thrown probably a dozen baby
showers because I throw a great baby
shower I don't want babies but I throw a
great baby shower it is so confused
about what I am I get garbage about not
garbage I get I get
marketingu yeah stuff that's garbage to
to your point to me right if I get if I
get New York Giants if I get New York
Giants stuff that's garbage to
me I'm a jet bad you know but but if
they understand that I want something
funny when I'm scrolling through Tik Tok
even if it's baby stuff I might pay
attention because I'm TR to funny in
that moment yeah but if I'm looking for
toothpaste and I'm in an analytical
thinking mode it doesn't matter whether
I'm 60 or I'm 20 that's when you can
deliver the efficacy stats so what we
have to understand is how people are
processing at different moments and make
that match and this is I do a lot of
this in Consulting this is what we do we
analyze the the whole journey for
processing style and then you can do
something that allows you to tailor at
scale um but you know you have to you
have to let go of some assumptions and
you have to kind of back up from some of
the really charming and Rich Work that
gets we down into the details um because
it can limit your ability to scale and
it can be so
wrong it uh it can eliminate your
ability to scale if the cost of the
creative and the hours deployed against
it aren't for a meaning enough scale
actually impact your business y exactly
thank you thank you great talking
you that was fantastic thank you Gary
soon take it away next up we've got one
of my favorites kayn mcamera in the
house she's our chief business officer
hi
kayn a little Sunny behind me I know
it's good you got the Angelic view we
could use a little sunshine in a 30
degree uh Northeastern weather weather
pattern I think we're going to bring on
some heat we got some heat coming next
with Mandy Rossy she's the CMO of
Michaels so nice to see you hi I can't
believe you guys have 1300 stores and
you're running all the e-commerce as
well oh my goodness yeah yeah you got I
think Michaels is sometimes bigger than
people think um yeah 1300 stores almost
well I can't wait to listen to this one
so I'm gonna let you guys take it away
awesome Andria hi there we'll get right
into to it um just knowing your career
most recently in retail but also cpg
analytics companies I'd imagine this
concept of brand forance is not a new
one for you in terms of how do you
balance sort of brand building with sort
of the demand generation that's required
at any company but obviously the
landscape has also changed dramatically
even probably in between the two last
gigs you've even had would love to hear
about kind of what have been some of the
unlocks for you and where have you found
success in following brand and
performance activities whether it's in
your current role or even in previous
gigs as well yeah sure I mean a lot of
it has been said uh very well said by
those who who came before me um so much
is about the consumer right to go back
to what Janelle said as well um and
understanding your your consumer where
they are in a journey where they are in
that moment in time but then also your
brand so I'll use Michaels as an example
we are a promotional brand so promotions
and performance is part of the DNA of
our brand and it's what customers expect
from us our category is also very high
low so that's different than like when I
was at PNG working on like tide or
Pampers it manifested in a little bit of
a different way just based on what the
DNA of the brand is um but I always tell
my team which others have said this as
well like everything has to be on brand
and everything has to perform it's just
about getting clear on what the kpi is
that you're optimizing towards so for
Michaels like right now we're going into
our holiday season um which is probably
not surprising so it's and actually a
little bit of what Kate just said it's
knowing when do I I want to lead so
Pinterest would be a great example
people are there for inspiration we know
our customer is very maximalist when it
comes to the holiday season so we want
to lead there with the beautiful
Christmas tree and the room that's
decked out and maybe a thing of like you
could click here and see how to make
this project um and all this stuff may
be on sale when they click through and
they will see that but we've seen even
in AB testing leading with the price
point in Pinterest doesn't work because
that's not what the audience is there
for whereas like in meta actually it
works a lot more like a promotional ad
and leading with all trees are up to 60%
off this week and you can get a rewards
bonus you know if you buy between these
dates is going to work a little bit
better and then the tree is still
beautiful in the background but but it's
a little bit of we have the DNA of our
brand which is both inspirational if you
want to call that the brand stuff and
very promotionally driven we're in
retail and and it's a little bit of just
knowing like which one is going to lead
in which moments and how do we get that
balance right for where our customer is
today which right now um I'm sure there
may be others in retail out there it's a
really challenging moment and we are in
a very discretionary category so you
know if we talk to our customers about
one people love doing creative projects
so it's a we're in a fun space because
Michaels is a happy place for a customer
to go their main barrier right now is
like yeah I want to do all that stuff
but I don't have the the free cash to do
it so they need the discounts they need
the rewards offers things like that to
help get over what their main sort of
trial or purchase barrier is right now
maybe other times it's the know how to
do it so it's it's kind of knowing who
we're talking to and sort of where their
mindset is and what that context is and
just playing with the dials yeah the
contextual relevance of the distribution
of those messages is what really what
kind of the the strategy is kind of in a
modern world speaking of contextual
relevance of brand as a loyal uh
customer myself I've noticed the glow up
recently um with the 50th anniversary I
know that the brand has undergone uh
kind of an evolution of the identity you
have a new tagline around kind of
everything to create anything tell us
about the impetus of this refresh and
this Evolution and how you see it uh
playing into the long-term growth
strategy for the brands yeah so a few
things um yes we turned 50 this month
which is very exciting um 50 is the new
30 by the way yes good thank you I
appreciate that on a personal basis as
well um you know Michaels has been on a
transformation journey I joined the
brand about a year and a half ago and
kind of in that same time frame the
business has transformed so we obviously
throughout Co there was a a big boom in
arts and crafts as people were doing
more creative projects when they were at
home um but obviously there was a lot of
Ecom transformation that went along with
that so um even just in the last year
we've rep platformed our site we've
launched our our thirdparty Market Place
business we just launched our Maker
Place business um it actually came out
of beta earlier this week which is our
handmade Marketplace we're opening new
small format Stores um we launched a
credit card we relaunched our Rewards
program so there had been a lot of real
transformation around the customer
experience of Michaels as a whole and um
the brand had not really evolved to tell
that story and even just where the
consumer mindset was our our prior
branding had been done at the end of
2019 um and really carried through covid
um which was not a promotional time for
all all the reasons many of us know at
this point in time duee to supply chain
and other things um so it worked really
well for the big inspirational
storytelling it was very influencer
Centric um but the promotional actually
had gotten lost as well so we we were
sort of coming out of that covid time
frame with a a business that had
transformed so it was time to look at
The Branding as well and one of the big
things very relevant to the brand
formance conversation is we need to show
up as one brand and as promos had sort
of started to come back late 21 into 22
Michaels had evolved to to there was
like beautiful brand campaign stuff that
would run and then all the promotional
work literally looked like a different
brand looked very Promotional and it was
like these two things don't quite fit so
we needed to sort of take a step back
and say look we are here to serve all
creative people now across this sort of
broader playing field that Michaels um
now has in front of us and we need it
all to feel cohesive and so some of it
was um yes there's like the bigger brand
messages our campaign is all about
helping people go from ideas to I did it
um but even like having a design system
that works really hard and can Flex up
and down was one of the biggest things
we needed and now especially fast
forward to more AI driven content
automation having a design system that
is flexible but tight also helps to
drive that consistency as we pump out a
lot more content some of which a human
creates and some of which might get put
together in other ways
love it I'd love to click down more into
makerplace because I know that that was
new news officially sort of would love
to hear more I think what's amazing
about sort of the platform is it feels
very from the community um and it feels
very informed by what seems like a kind
of a lot of listening you've done as an
organization so would love to understand
a little bit of sort of what led to the
launch of that platform and where do you
see that kind of playing in the in the
long-term strategy as well yes so first
thank you for saying that we have worked
very hard to have makeer Place really be
a place that is all about about
celebrating all things handmade so it is
our handmade Marketplace you will you
know our aspiration is you're only going
to find handmade stuff there so it's not
drop ship items we sell a lot of that
stuff on the Michael side but this is
really for people one who are are
Michaels customers we know there are a
lot of them who are sellers um who maybe
go to craft fairs or they were selling
previously on Etsy um and we wanted to
give them a solution within the Michaels
ecosystem to do that and we did spend a
lot of time with them to understand
really what their aspirations are we
want to help them grow their business we
are doing it with significantly lower
fees than the other available options no
listing fees um to hopefully make this a
very maker friendly site where we can
support um our customers and growing
their businesses uh we heard from the
makers that um three quarters of them
said they they felt like there was a lot
of um need for a better solution in this
space and then we worked with them to
really design around that at the same
time time we know our creative customers
on the Michael side also love to buy
handmade Goods uh so this allows us to
sort of meet both the seller and buyer
piece together um and hopefully offer
some really unique and handcrafted
things um really that does create a
community we also offer classes and
how-tos so if you're someone who's maybe
you see a beautiful crocheted thing and
you think that's so cool that maker
might actually offer a class so you can
learn how to do some of that yourself um
and then it's nice for the makers
because we give them more ways to earn
earn so it's not just making the goods
you sell but you can teach a class and
if you fill it up you're going to make
more money or you have how to um you
know sort of affiliate list so if you do
a class and then you go and buy things
from that list from Michaels then they
actually get some reward on that as well
so yeah we're excited literally came out
of beta like a day ago so it it's still
very early days but um we've gotten lots
of of great feedback uh we already have
over 10,000 stores and you know we're
like a day and obviously in beta we
signed some people up mainly through
Word of Mouth um so we're really excited
to see where it goes I'm excited with
Halloween behind us it's officially
Christmas in my family so I'm headed
into hosting and gifting mindset so I'm
excited to check it out um but
appreciate the time I know we're at time
but thank you so much it's so exciting
all momentum and appreciate your time
awesome thanks bye thanks you guys that
was fantastic thank you Kalen all right
next up we have
Christina we've got some exciting news
um her her her name is going to come up
as as something that she's not because
she just got
married so we like to call Christina X
around here and that's never gonna
change never some superpowers um but
Christina is no longer blankin ship she
is now
Mara yes I know I need a hard launch
strategy yeah exactly it's happening
today new brand new brand refresh
excellent well we're really excited to
bring Jason Brock um up for a dialogue
around all of his fantastic work um
specifically and performance and how he
drives that for St Jude which is
phenomenal organization um we've had the
luxury of working with Jason for quite
some time so thank you so much for
joining today and looking forward to
this conversation you guys thanks for
having me and congratulations thank you
yeah I forgot to mention that right
surprise yeah hard launch the name next
marketing for the now um thank you thank
you so much for joining us um I've known
you for a few years such an honor to
work with you guys we'll get a chance to
talk about the mission and all the
amazing things you guys are up to I
would love if you could just start with
a little bit of context on your
background as a performance marketer and
just give us a sense for what you're up
to at St Jude well I kind of consider
this my third leg of my career if you
will at my early days I was in financial
services the early days of online
banking so really started from a digital
product perspective and there's where I
kind of develop a passion for product
user EXP experience and consumer
behavior and then I made a pretty big
leap I made a leap into the marketing
agency world what began as a small
digital startup just grew to be part of
one of the large holding companies and
we focused on performance media and
analytics for Fortune 1,000
organizations and that's a season where
we have the shared passion of love and
for numbers really grew right we talk
about numbers a lot love doing that love
solving big problems for clients but
honestly there was something that was
still missing for me I love the work
love the client but was really craving a
more tangible way to connect my
day-to-day with a bigger purpose and
that Journey led me here it led me here
to the fundraising warus Organization
for St Jude and this Mission has just
been incredible huge Global impact and
allows me to just leverage that love of
data and media and apply it to something
much bigger yeah I mean um even being in
an agency it's like the highlight of my
career getting to apply what we do to
such an amazing cause um we don't
usually get that honor on this scale too
um but St Jude is such an incredible
example of brand forance because the
entire objective of marketing is Raising
donations it's very Dr focused in a
sense but you could really argue that
that TV strategy that you guys have had
for many years and are really famous for
um these twom minute spots explaining
patient stories and capturing really the
impact while still collecting donations
with phone number QR code that was brand
forance all along for all these years so
you guys being a Pioneer in brand
forance digitally isn't all that
surprising but I would love to hear how
you guys have um changed that approach
and what that looks like for you now
yeah that that fundraising you mentioned
it's an awesome
resp responsibility the reality is that
takes over2 billion dollars a year to
fund the operations of St Jude and the
science and research and patient care
there so yeah started with I'd say those
drtv two-minute spots you mentioned but
also direct mail and radiothon those are
early examples of brand informance for
us so we know that consumer Behavior
changes have evolved over time but the
foundation still holds true um when I
think pre-pandemic I also think about
YouTube we were early adopters of
YouTube's action-based campaigns and
that's really where we started to move
the needle from thinking about YouTube
as a performance driver and not just a
brand building platform so for over two
years our top ad on YouTube take a guess
how long it was take a
guess 15 seconds five minutes and 13
seconds right so powerful content always
wins now yeah in the era of tiktock
ification of everything right as we
think about attention span so the speed
of content consumption overwhelming
challenge of audience attention so maybe
we should jump into Tik Tok and kind of
some of our brand forance life there
yeah I mean you guys are experts in that
space and we've learned just as much
from your team about how to do brand
forance on Tik Tok as I hope we've been
able to help you guys with but um would
love to hear what it's unlocked for you
because I know at an organization that's
um really really focused on making sure
that that bottom line stays consistent
every year being Innovative in a
platform like Tik Tok probably took a
lot so would love to hear a little bit
more about the effort behind the scenes
to get to that point and all the things
that it has unlocked for you now that
you have a really well oiled machine
well I'd say embracing brand forance was
honestly out of necessity right most of
us marketers we've heard the phrase
don't make ads make Tik toks well the
data plays that out um but really the
most surprising thing for me on that
platform was how fast that creative
fatigues right the platform like Tik Tok
it moves at the speed of culture so you
practically can't have a sit it and
forget it model so for us that meant we
had to have fresh organic content and we
had to constantly take that organic
content that had traction and we had to
spark it and it was out of necessity as
much as anything yeah but it also
probably was an enormous shift not only
in the performance marketing side what
you needed to facilitate but on the
creative side and the amount of output
that you needed to generate and then um
probably the level of collaboration that
you have with your brand counterparts
and performance as brand formance came
together how did you guys as an
organization bring together brand and
performance yeah I think for a lot of
marketing organizations they set up
brand and performance almost as a
competing system and we know that can't
be the case I think for us there's
there's really three important things we
did the first thing we actually do is
for every employee they have an annual
brand goal every employee so brand
health is Paramount and all we do it
stays in our DNA and then operationally
we brought brand advertising and
performance media together one team
optimized under a single media mix
so that makes ease of optimization in
terms of budgets and allocation so
depending on audience attention or
donation intent we can easily move and
then the last thing I'd say and this is
the hardest one maybe for all of us is
what I'll call our 180 degree effect
many marketers start with a creative
approach then how do we push that across
every media channel in market and then
report on which audiences respond we got
to flip that to be audience L we got to
start with what are the audiences in
mind okay where are those audiences
let's understand where they are and then
produce contextually relevant content
based on that audience and that platform
and it's easy to say that it's hard to
operationalize that
yes yeah we have a phrase here modern
comms planning and I don't know what you
guys call it but it is truly flipping
the entire model on its head and once
you see it you really can't unsee it
right and I'm sure it took a while for
everybody at St Jude to see it um how
did you really spend your time building
that foundation for everybody well I
think it's it's a Journey right we're
we're not in complete in that I think a
lot of it is uh incrementality testing
is important I think as marketers we
also talk a lot about demand creation
versus demand capture and we think about
how do you balance that which implies
5050 the reality is it's not 5050
depending on the marketplace and your
business objectives um a lot of direct
consumer Brands focus on I think yeah
look we we managed to clone him in
different forms I think oh dear oh dear
well if I can just round out with one
quick thing we got to put brand forance
in action here and so if anybody heard
the message appreciated it um felt
resonance with the mission of St Jude
would really appreciate any donations
you can go to stjude.org um it's Q4
every single dollar counts and as Jason
said every single um aspect of the
organization runs based off donations
from marketing department patient care
no family or child ever faces a bill
because of the humanity of people like
who are on this call so any amount um
really helps and would appreciate any
donations I think Jason would be proud
of you Christina for that one always s
yeah we love the work is so important
that they do and it's um yeah it's such
an honor oh we got we got some some
people that are screaming in the
background addal fans back there I guess
oh my goodness all right well let's go
fa save Jason hope everything's okay on
his side yeah thank you thank you so
much and congratulations Christina thank
you see you fantastic IC all right next
up we have Chris Anthony from Gallery
Media Group hey Chris how you doing hi
Andre how are you good you're always
bringing up the the power on the on the
the tail end of the show thanks for
joining all right we we have a great
conversation to round things out so
we've got Patrick O'Keefe who joins us
from Elf Beauty and Patrick what don't
you do is All I'm gonna ask I mean this
list of everything from Paid media
social Med media influencer marketing PR
and it's not just for one brand but the
full portfolio at elf I'm exhausted just
even talking about
it well it's good to see you nice to see
you I'll let you guys take it away all
right thanks Andrea Patrick so good to
see you likewise how are you Chris I'm
good I'm excited for this huge obviously
fan of the brand and all the work you
guys do so I'm excited we're ending the
show with some good insights from you
love it um the topic today is brand
forance how do you as like a
organization just think about branding
and performance overall from a
philosophy
standpoint we love our community
everything we do is centered around our
community we listen we learn we are a
brand of the People by the people and
for the people so at the end of every
day we read all of our comments our CMO
Corey marotto is in there all the time
and we are connecting based on what
we're we're seeing and we're reviewing
it and making action against it I love
it the power of comments on social is is
pretty wild and so amazing you guys use
that to inform so much of the work um
there's so much fun stuff to get through
um with what you guys are doing but one
thing I think comes to mind is you know
how do you guys think about culture and
talent and creators you have so many I
think examples of wins I mean Jennifer
kulage I feel like you guys really
struck gold um with that partnership but
talk a little bit about just creators
and talent and culture and what has that
done in terms of building the
brand it they have to be authentic to
the brand first they have to love it
first at the end of the at the end of
the day if we if we think about what we
did with Jennifer coolage um she Lov the
brand her social person was using the
product and Jennifer asked him what the
product was and she's like let's play
with it let's try it she tried it she
loved it and that was the start of that
beautiful relationship and then of
course her Access Hollywood Cameo when
when the reporter asked her hey you know
what what do you want your next role to
be and she said I want to be a dolphin
of course dolphin skin was trending on
Tik Tok so connecting the dots really
helped us Propel that commercial and
into our next campaign that we just
launched recently with dirty pillows she
is an an incredible incredible talent
and we are so grateful to have her as
part of our family as we continue to
build um the brand and what I love even
more is the comments that people our
community going back to the community
what they say is they we we love her
anything she puts out there we will buy
is truly what they say and then the
other comments they make is this is what
marketing should be this is what
advertising should be people having fun
in the space just having leaning into a
cultural moment and finding your way in
I love that and I think to your point so
many people areer talk about
authenticity and it can just be a word
we throw around but I feel like the way
you just describe that partnership is
just definitely the definition of that
so congrats I love that is continue of
the work and and watching that Journey
go on um we talked a lot about platforms
today and obviously they're a big core
of how you guys talk to your community I
think of Elf as really sort of writing
the playbook for Tech Tik Tok I think
you guys were really early on on that
platform and um got tons of press and
were really looked at as a thought
leader in this space and I think so many
people then started taking cues and
building off that success how do you
guys think about Tik Tok continually you
know in the world today Ren what do you
think is next of using that platform
talk a little bit about that yeah no I
love that question I Tik Tok obviously
is is there's a lot of there are lot
many platforms that's I want to say that
too because I think they're all equally
important they all serve a different
Purpose with Tik Tok specifically you
know the eyes lips face song early on in
our journey was really what propelled us
into the billion what we call the
billionaires Club from a views
perspective we did a partnership with
Gamers Got Talent as we entered into the
gaming space gen generated a lot more AB
billion a billion more views for us and
I and I love our new collaboration that
right now we did with Manuel tereso is
we're leaning in in um into a community
that really is about empowering women
and we just created another ohos Laos
Cara song eyes lips face Spanish and
what's super cool about that that
partnership is that you know Tik Tok was
another place that we're leaning in to
help expand it's finding new audiences
it's leaning in where you find the right
Trend or the right comment that could
trigger something we have an insights
team and every week we sit down and we
sit around a table and we talk about
what we're learning we see something we
say something and then we do something
and I think that's really powerful for
companies that really take action when
you are listening to a community of
people that really help to shape culture
yeah and and to your point just the
insights are so powerful and the fact
you guys are putting those in practice
is is really important and really
commendable in the vein of of brand you
know standing for something I think is
you know obviously so important
especially in you know the younger
generation and really every generation
especially in the world we are in today
talk a little about purpose what what
does purpose mean for the brand and to
elf and to
you wow it's everything we we always we
have a framework and which we really
lean into it's we are bold disruptors
with a kind heart we disrupt Norms we
shape culture and we connect communities
that is a framework that we lean into
every project that we do or every
campaign anytime we sit in a room we
always ask the question and it always
has to lean come back to a sense of
purpose when I think about you know
we're one of only four out of 4,200
publicly traded companies that have
2third women and and onethird diverse
that is incredible thing to to put out
there and it makes me so proud to be
part of a company that really honors and
celebrates women and diversity and more
and and they put action behind it I also
when I think about what we did with
Billy Jean King I mean she is really um
a true Testament about something that
she stood for and she believed around
equal pay for equal play what she did
with battle of the sexes and it it was
really an honor to sit to meet her a and
to be a for her to be a part of really
helping to shape what we're trying to do
to really Empower young women in the in
in the World of
Sports I love that yeah just constantly
you guys keep on you know spotting new
interesting collaborations it
continually just gets better and better
you talked about this really quickly um
you know when we talk about the platform
space Tik Tok um and you mentioned
gaming a little bit that seems to be you
know a space that's continually you know
helping reach new audiences different
types of engagements talk a little about
that overall as a category for you guys
yeah I I I love it and it's it's just it
we we started a channel on Twitch it's
called lfu um what we learned is that
that a lot of excuse me women were being
bullied on the platform and you know we
were like well that's that's not cool we
were a brand of really celebrating and
empowering women and they're getting you
know abused on the channel so we we
partnered with loser fruit who's the
number two women gamer in in this space
she's based out of Australia who and she
is so elf and she's got a she is a bold
disruptor with a kind heart for sure and
we created a channel called U and it's
basically about you know celebrating
women giving women a safe space giving
them a place to really do makeup hang
out and just really connect and on a
deeper level and and really celebrate
you know what they'd love to do which is
gaming yeah I love that I mean it
definitely tracks back to your whole
point around you know being authentic
and purpose-driven but doing it in a
space that you know was interesting at
the same time so so great um what last
question really for you and I think you
touched upon this a little bit in some
of the other parts but another thing I
think you guys are continually known for
is just is collaborations that some of
the the things you guys have done with
other brands that have been super
disruptive what have you learned from
there um that's I think gonna
continually take you guys into next year
with exciting um continuations on that
front talk a little bit about that yeah
no listen it all it's it's all about
about connecting dots and we we like I
said we read the comments we see
something and then we say something and
then we do something and we lean in and
it's about an Insight if I think about
Megan Trainer The Weather Channel why
would we do something with Megan Trainer
eight out of 10 women change their
beauty Behavior because of because of
the weather wow that's a powerful
Insight she was also trending on Tik Tok
so again connecting the dots she wanted
to be a weather woman right
wow it was like the perfect storm and so
of course for us we wanted to really
find a way that made sense that's
authentic that creates a little bit of
of humor and and have some fun along the
way and she she did an amazing job of
really finding a way to really take our
one of our products and make it another
another really big Big Brand on Tik Tok
it's awesome so so much great work that
you guys continue to do
congratulations um on everything and I
can't wait to see what happens in 24
which is around the corner I'm sure
there'll be a million other exciting
things to talk to you guys about um and
for you guys to share with the world so
congrat oh there's more coming for sure
I I am sure thanks Chris appreciate
thank you so much uh for joining us
today thanks you guys for closing us out
thank you we got another episode that's
upcoming uh in just I think it's like 13
days uh we're g to be focusing on how we
unlock a growth mindset and we've got
some exciting Brands uh that include
Stuart whitesman WNBA Vans CR H&R Block
sopi and we have one other mystery brand
that's coming soon so we hope to see you
very very soon on that episode and until
then please take care of yourselves
thanks so much for joining marking for
the